Let's put
Gods,
Absolute authority
Underneath that song
Like a rock foundation.
So that you don't feel that song just as.
Poetic sentiment or
Musical pleasure alone
But as unshakable.
reality and I have in mind
Not just the thousands of believers in this room, but the hundreds of you.
Who have come
By Providence,
That you might believe
I see three.
Paradoxes
In what?
Was your song
Number one.
We are unworthy of Christ.
And we have great worth.
Because of christ.
At the cross.
Number two.
With all your worth
You are not
Your own treasure
Christ is
at the cross
Number three
Trust,
That
That looks away from self to Christ.
Becomes
the ultimate satisfaction of the self.
At the cross let's take those one at a time
and put God's authority
Underneath them
and I invite you to hear for your own soul.
Number one.
We are unworthy of Christ.
And
We have great worth.
Because of christ.
The final verse went like this.
Two wonders here that I confess.
my worth
And my unworthiness.
my value fixed my ransom paid
at the cross
One of the most beautiful sentences in the Bible is that
Jesus Christ came into the world to save sinners.
What is sin?
Sin is a mindset that prefers other things more than God.
and therefore sin exchanges God
Four created things.
and therefore sin belittles God, demeans God, is rebellious
Against,
God
And that's who we are, every one of you.
we are that way.
There is none righteous, no, not one.
Christ died for us, not because we are worthy,
But because we are unworthy and there was no other way,
For us to be made worthy
While we were still weak at the right time, Christ died for the ungodly.
for one will scarcely die for a righteous man yet perhaps for a good man one might dare to die.
But God shows his love for us in the while we were yet sinners, Christ died.
For us
We are saved by the
Grace.
The death of Jesus is not...
Divine compliance with fair trade laws.
it wasn't a fair trade
The Son of God died, rebels lived.
That's not fair!
that's grace.
And that's how I stand here.
As a result, what happens?
Jesus put it like this:
Are not two sparrows sold for a penny?
And not one of them falls to the ground apart from your father. Fear not!
You are of more value than many sparrows.
Because of the cross.
That's paradox number one.
We're unworthy.
of the cross.
Because of the cross.
We are worthy.
Paradox number two.
With all your worth
You are not
Your own treasure
Christ is.
Because of the cross.
The refrain of the song goes like this:
I rejoice in my Redeemer.
greatest treasure wellspring of my soul
Why didn't why didn't the verse come to a climax like this? I rejoice in my new worth.
I am my new treasure. I am the new wellspring of my soul. I am at last so
Somebody.
Why didn't...
The cross result in that kind of song.
it didn't.
Why not?
Why won't we sing for ages long that I am my treasure?
You won't sing that way in heaven. Heaven is not a hall of mirrors.
Where the greatest joy is that we get to like what we see.
You were made for something infinitely better.
Then yourself.
Your your soul, your worth could never satisfy you.
Ever!
You weren't made!
To find deepest satisfaction in having worth.
Andrew just read
Revelation 5.
worthy are you. Now this is the way they sing.
In celebration of being redeemed into
Priests to God.
Kingdom.
Of god
You are worthy, O Christ. You are worthy, for you were slain, and by your blood you ran some people for God from every tribe and tongue and people and nation.
And you have made them a kingdom and preached to our God and they shall reign on the earth.
The song that breaks out in heaven forever is not,
Look!
Traitors got in. blasphemers are now priests. that's not the song. the song is worthy. are you you were made?
You were made.
To be made priest, to be made a kingdom so that you could enjoy.
Making much of him.
As lord you you will never be worthy enough to be your own treasure
You were made to treasure Him above all.
Oh, you can't be the wellspring of your own soul.
Because of the cross
Last paradox number three
Trust,
That looks away from self
to Christ,
Becomes the ultimate
Satisfaction of the self.
because of the cross. Here's the way the refrain ends.
Greatest treasure
wellspring of my soul
I will try
Trust.
In him no other
My soul is satisfied in Him.
Alone.
And I ask you now as I draw to a close.
Do you want that?
do you want to be a christian?
Do you want to be able to say my worth?
Is in the costly woods.
Is in the blood that flowed.
Do you want to be able to say
My value fixed.
My ransom paid at the cross.
How do you become a Christian?
How do you become a true Christian?
and you know the answer almost everybody in this country would probably say something like
trust Jesus
What's that mean?
What does that mean?
How do you trust?
A treasure.
What does it mean to trust a well-springed
The song tells us
the bible tells us
my soul is satisfied in him
Alone.
What does a loan mean in that song?
Really?
that doesn't mean
You can't.
Tonight, enjoy a meal.
It doesn't mean you can't enjoy friends.
It means
All those gifts.
All those gifts of Christ.
are now means by which you taste Christ.
More of Christ.
And it means if
Christ takes them away.
All the friends, all the food and your life, he's enough.
He is all satisfying as your treasure and your wellspring. that's what alone means.
He's there in everything, he's there after everything, and he's enough.
To trust.
A treasure.
Is to embrace and rest
In him
As your
Satisfaction like
That.
It's the gift of grace.
I offer him to you. Jesus offers himself.
To you,
And,
I would like to pray
For you, if I could have come.
to Northern Ireland,
Just to pray what I'm about to pray.
it would be enough.
Let's pray.
Father, it is grace.
that anyone would listen to me now
It will be grace if anyone
Is leaning and longing into
This song, this truth,
This word from you
And I ask,
For the grace
of treasure in Christ.
That is.
Saving faith.
I ask, Lord, if there are people right now who are saying,
I can't.
Do that.
I pray that they would at least
Pray for the strength to do it.
And I ask Lord for...
Every believer in this room
That they would so treasure christ.
that christ would be such a well-springed
Of joy,
For their souls through all their troubles
That they would have courage to commend Christ to every person in this nation.
Indeed,
In this
Island.
And lastly, Lord, I ask,
that if any is saying
As we all do,
I don't know if I can
Last
I don't know if tonight's...
Sense of calling on my life will last.
I'm young or I'm old and I don't know if I can persevere that far in this new thing you're calling me to do.
I pray, Lord, that as we sing now,
You would answer that
Question.
You will hold us fast. that's the only way we'll make it.
Lord, draw people now.
Into this song
And into yourself
Forever.